cuatro años después cientos de miles de
rohingyas siguen a la deriva en agosto
de 2017 más de 700 mil personas de esta
minoría musulmana huyeron de mí al mar
escapaban de una violencia aterradora la
organización save the children indica
que al menos la mitad de estos
refugiados eran menores de edad cuyos
padres fueron asesinados y que muchos de
ellos fueron blancos de violencia sexual
o sufrieron mutilaciones la onu ha
catalogado esta crisis como una limpieza
étnica lo roig en ya quienes mi alma
negó la nacionalidad en 1982
convirtiéndolos en apátridas han vivido
por décadas oprimidos y sin ningún
estado que los proteja en 2017 la
violencia se desató como represalia tras
ataques de insurgentes musulmanes a
puestos de policía y militares entonces
el ejército inició una represión masiva
con la vista gorda de la comunidad
internacional en medio de la violencia
cientos de miles huyeron a bangladesh
donde la mayoría aguarda aún en campos
de refugiados desde entonces dependen
principalmente de ongs que financian
campamentos como los de cox bazar
lugares donde no hay garantías a los
derechos básicos de vivienda
alimentación educación o comida en estos
cuatro años los rohingya han hecho
frente a inundaciones a la pandemia de
coronavirus y por si fuera poco en marzo
un incendio arrasó los campos de cox
bazar y dejó docenas de muertos y a
50.000 personas sin refugio en 2019 la
corte internacional de justicia recibió
una demanda por genocidio contra la
líder del país la controversial premio
nobel de la paz aún san suu kyi quien
negó ante el tribunal las acusaciones en
marzo de 2020 la corte ordenó a mianmar
proteger a los rohingyas que quedan
dentro del país pero con el golpe de
estado de 2021 la minoría musulmana ha
quedado más que nunca a merced de los
militares